pour le président russe il est temps de
passer à la vitesse supérieure jusque là
le vaccin était proposée progressivement
à différentes catégories de la
population les premiers étant les
professions prioritaires comme le
personnel soignant
puis ensuite fin décembre où plus de 60
ans et donc à partir de ce lundi 18
janvier toute la population doit
dorénavant pouvoir en bénéficier
concernant le vaccin russe nous le
pensions avant et l'expérience le montre
il est tout à fait évident qu'il est à
mon avis le meilleur du monde
aucun autre médicament de ce genre ne
fait preuve de ce niveau de protection
et de sécurité
c'est une réussite indiscutable je vous
demande de lancer dès la semaine
prochaine une campagne de vaccination de
masse de l'ensemble de la population et
d'établir un calendrier de sa mise en
oeuvre
vladimir poutine a souligné qu'il était
nécessaire de se préparer en termes
d'infrastructures et de logistique mais
par chance je cite le vaccin russe ne
nécessite pas de conditions de transport
et de conservation inhabituelle le
président russe fait ici allusion au
vaccin de pfizer qui a besoin d'être
stockés à moins 70 degrés et qui se
révèle être un casse tête logistique
pour les pays qui y ont recours
il n'en reste pas moins que la tâche va
s'avérer longue et complexe mais si son
stockage et sa conservation ne pose pas
de problème
il faudra malgré tout faire parvenir le
spoutnik vais à travers tout le pays
mais aussi vaincre les réticences à se
faire vacciner d'une partie de la
population
enfin certains s'interrogent sur la
capacité de la russie à produire
rapidement les dizaines de millions de
doses nécessaires